find the area of a square with side six
X minus five Y so let me draw our square
and all of the sides of a square we're
going to have the same lengths and
they're telling us that the length for
each of the sides which is the same for
all of them is 6x minus 5y so the height
would be 6x minus 5y and so with the
width 6x minus 5y and if we wanted to
find the area of the square we just have
to multiply the width times the height
so the area for this square is just
going to be the width which is 6x minus
5y times the height times the height
which is also 6x minus 5y so we just
have to multiply these two binomials and
to do this you could either do foil if
you like memorizing things or you can
just remember this is just applying the
distributive property twice so we could
do is distribute this entire magenta 6x
minus 5y times each of distribute it
over each of these terms in the yellow
6x minus 5y and if we do that we will
get this 6x this six x times this entire
6x minus 5y so 6x minus 5y and then we
have minus 5y minus 5y times once again
the entire magenta 6x minus 5y and what
does this give us so we have we have 6x
times 6x so the when I distribute it
just this where I'm now doing the
distributive property for the second
time 6x times 6x is 36 x squared and
then when I take 6x and then when I take
6x times negative 5y I get 6 times
negative 5 is negative 30 and then I
have an x times y negative 30 X Y and
then I want to take and then I want to
take I'm trying to introduce many colors
here so I have this negative 5y times
this 6x right over here so negative 5
times 6 is negative 30
negative 30 and I have a Y an X or an X
and a y and then finally I have my last
distribution to do let me do that maybe
in white I have five Y times I'll
actually have a negative 5y times
another negative 5y so the negative
times a negative is a positive so it is
positive five times five is twenty-five
Y times y is y squared and then we are
almost we are almost done right over
here we could say we can just add these
two terms in the middle right over here
negative 30 XY minus third 30 XY is
going to be negative 60 XY so you get 36
x squared minus 60 XY plus 25y squared
now there is a faster way to do this if
you recognize if you recognize that if
I'm squaring a binomial which is
essentially what we're doing here this
is the exact same thing as 6x minus 5y
squared so you might recognize the
pattern if I have a plus B squared this
is the same thing as a plus B times a
plus B and if you were to multiply it
out this exact same way we just did it
here the pattern here is it's a times a
which is a squared plus a times B plus a
B plus B times a which is also a B if
you just switch the order plus B squared
plus B squared so this is equal to a
squared plus 2 a B plus B squared this
is kind of the fast way to look whenever
if you're squaring any binomial it'll be
a plus B squared will be a squared plus
2 a B plus B squared and if you knew
this ahead of time then you could have
just applied that to this to the
squaring of the binomial right up here
so we let's do it that way as well so if
we have 6x 6x minus 5y squared we could
just say well this is going to be a
squared it's going to be a squared in
which in this case is 6x squared plus 2
a B so that's plus 2 times a
which is 6x times B which is negative 5y
negative 5y plus B squared which is plus
negative 5y everything squared and then
this will simplify to 6 x squared is 36
x squared plus actually there's going to
be a negative here because it's going to
be 2 times 6 is 12 times negative 5 is
negative 60 we have x and a y x and a y
and the negative 5y squared is positive
25 y squared so hopefully you saw
multiple ways to do this if you saw this
pattern immediately and if you knew this
pattern immediately you could just cut
to the chase and go straight here you
wouldn't have to do the distributive
property twice although this will never
be wrong